most people look at law school as some
inscrutable ivory tower as a result
there are a huge number of myths about
what happens when you start law school
so today let's talk about some of the
three biggest myths about starting law
school and why they're wrong so let's
dive in to the biggest myths about
starting law school the first myth is
everybody knows what they want to do
when they graduate in reality very few
people go to law school knowing exactly
what they want to do when they graduate
from law school you may have a general
idea that you want to go into public
interest law or you want to become a
civil litigator or you want to go into
criminal defense but very few people
know exactly the subfield exactly the
firm that they want to go to and in fact
most people will change their conception
of what they want to do when they
graduate so don't be afraid to go to law
school not knowing exactly which firm
and which section of law you want to
practice when you graduate in reality
very few people know exactly what they
want to do and those things change over
time now on the other hand you should
have a general idea and you should be
damn sure that you definitely want to be
a lawyer or you want to go into some
field that requires a law degree before
you go to law school it's a huge waste
to go to law school not knowing for sure
that you in fact want to do something
that requires a lot agree law school
these days cost hundreds of thousands of
dollars it can cost over two hundred
thousand dollars when you factor in
living expenses so that is a huge
penalty to play if you aren't a hundred
percent sure that you want to be a
lawyer or you need a law degree for the
field you want to go into so well you
don't need to know exactly what you want
to do it's a good idea to know that you
do absolutely need a law degree law
school is not the time to figure out
what you want to do with your life so
that takes me to myth number two and
that is everyone is super competitive
now certainly there are going to be a
lot of competitive people but not
everyone is a cutthroat
just like an undergrad there is a huge
spectrum of people who on one side are
incredibly competitive and on the other
side are complete slackers and while
there certainly aren't as many slackers
in law school as there are in undergrad
they certainly get into law school a
corollary to the myth that everyone is
super competitive is the myth that
everyone is incredibly mean on the
contrary I find that law students in
general are a very kind Bunch and some
of my best friends are the people that I
met in law school so don't think that
you're going to go into law school and
everyone is going to have their nose
buried in a book all day long
focused on nothing but acing their exams
certainly by the time that finals come
around everyone is probably going to
cocoon themselves but for the most part
law students are people just like
everybody else and not everyone is going
to be a super a-plus type personality
that doesn't care anything about anyone
else number three is that everyone has
legal experience before they go to law
school or in other words everybody knows
this stuff but me not true in fact very
few people have legal experience before
they go law school there are a handful
of people who work as paralegals or
legal secretaries but here's the secret
even if you had those jobs before you
went to law school that does not prepare
you for the law school experience and it
doesn't make you a very good law student
on the contrary the kind of day-to-day
things that paralegals do and legal
secretaries do the only thing I think it
would be helpful for is Civil Procedure
other than that they probably have no
further insights into the substantive
law that's gonna be tested as a 1l than
anybody else so in fact very few people
have legal experience and even the
people that do have legal experience
it's not the kind of experience that's
going to help them as a law student so
don't worry about gunners Gunners are
very vocal they seem like they know what
they're talking about but for the most
part they're actually less likely to do
well than everybody else so if you did
not have legal experience before going
to
Law School don't worry about it it's not
going to help the people that do have it
and it's not a hindrance to you not
having it if you liked this video please
click like and subscribe for more law
school crushing tips also please
download the checklist that's down below
it's free and it will help dispel all
the other myths about law school before
you get there
[Music]